welcome back to Rick's movie reviews so
apparently James Cameron's new movie is
going to be about blue aliens uh yeah
that's gonna fail honestly Titanic was
just fine overrated okay don't doubt
James Cameron he's always when Avatar is
under performing at the box office okay
Avatar has legs it is exploding at the
box office everyone and their Grandma
are seeing Avatar so apparently James
Cameron is taking his time on the sequel
to Avatar remember Avatar it had like no
cultural impact right James Cameron's
still working on his Avatar sequel I
mean will people care after all this
time Avatar 2 is delayed again let's be
real Avatar was mid No One's Gonna See
Avatar 2. Avatar 2 is underperforming at
the box office Avatar 2 has legs and it
is dominating the box office Avatar 2
was so overrated no cultural impact
Avatar 3 is underperforming at the box
office are people finally gonna see
James Cameron for the hack fraud he is
Avatar 3 has legs it is a masterpiece
the Avatar Series has left no cultural
impact yeah Avatar 4 made by billion
dollars and everyone's seeing it but
does it have any culture relevant Avatar
5 is bombing at the box office wait no
actually it's doing really well and
everyone loves the ghost of James
Cameron's AI is directing a new Avatar
sequel Avatar six is Me avatar 7 has had
no cultural Avatar 8 Avatar nine is
I don't see any cultural where are the
memes
[Music]